you've mentioned just referencing this
game uh on a Reddit AMA that long time
ago during Red Guard the lead programmer
made me
made all the buildings up up and down
after you played for 10 minutes just to
mess with me uh just a curious tangent
what What's um involved with programming
in open world game so so we talked about
we will talk about design and so on but
specifically the programming because I
think this question came from what are
some interesting sticky bugs that you've
encountered throughout your life in
creating these games and this is one of
them that you mentioned so what are some
of the challenges of
programming these open world games
I mean there are different flavors of
them right your gtas will have different
issues than
you know the Ubisoft games versus our
games things sort of you know speak to
ours
which is you want to build systems right
because they're gonna they're gonna play
the game for a very long time as well
which we've learned and
you can't go through and touch
everything by hand per se so you have to
rely on some systemic level of creation
and a lot of systems that are robust
enough so that when they touch another
one things aren't breaking apart
so there's like a what are the major
systems is there like the physics of the
game the engine of how like stuff
yeah like
um yeah the physics the motion and maybe
how light is rendered and all that kind
of stuff right so you have the rendering
right of like okay this is how I'm gonna
render the data that I have
so a lot of people confuse engines with
rendering I mean they're combined
obviously but there's the data you're
gonna give to a renderer which is the
thing that you know the audience you
know that draws the pixels on the screen
so there's a most of the engine is how
are you going to bring in that data and
give it to the renderer to to draw it so
you have that whole system of walking
through the world feeding in the data
and drawing it
you then obviously have the physics and
the interactivity
what are the things that are there just
to be drawn
and what are the things there that are
meant to be interacted with and touched
we put a big premium on the ones that
can be interacted with and touched
whether it's flowers whether the trees
move whether you can sleep on the sofa
sit in this chair pick up all this stuff
bake bread blah blah blah
you then have the AI which Loops in the
stuff we talked about earlier in terms
of processing everybody and
combat systems which is a lot of what
and the people end up doing combat
systems on top of that AI how do they
react to those types of things and then
how how do they look at the things that
can be interacted with one of my
favorite things is when NPCs will go
pick up weapons in the world but you
don't see in other games and the first
time you see it in one of ours like very
unexpected you can drop like a crazy
weapon be in a fight and an NPC runs
over picks it up and uses it on you it's
not something you would expect
um but I love that stuff and that's
integrated into a larger system the
ability to pick up the npcp accountable
so it's not like a little Quark that's
hard-coded in it's part of a bigger
system they they have their own AI for
scanning the environment that's one of
the rules hey is there a weapon
that is better than the one I have
I'm gonna go get it now we do lock off
if it's in a chest and that's treasure
we left for the player but it's in
particular
because what you don't want we actually
have this problem you start in Oblivion
I believe which is a separate level hey
let the enemies go pick up the you know
weapons if there are better so you make
a level and go in and wow all of the
enemies are armed of the teeth and
there's no treasure for the player
because the enemies went and took all
the good weapons and he's like okay they
don't take those they take the ones that
are dropped Yeah by other NPCs or the
player that's such a fascinating world
of exp of the design of the experience
for the NPC because in part that
experience
is uh defines the experience of the
player
so how they interact with their
environment defines how how the player
experiences their environment is there
room for further and further development
of the AI that controls the MPC
sure we're always iterating on it and
again as we look in the future
it's more about us finding those more
reactivity to the player and also
understanding their roles in the world
so they're not just there
they're not just there for the player as
a signpost for the player but they're
reacting to the player but what about
you know some of the richest experiences
we have with people is like the chaos of
it the pull the push and pull the
unpredictability is there something I
don't know if you've been following but
the the quick amazing development of
language models
uh the neural network
natural language processing systems
dialogue systems
do you think there's some possibility of
using
sort of these incredible neural Nets
that can have open-ended dialogue
basically chat Bots yep I've seen some
incredible demos I do think it's coming
I don't know when yeah
um and there's a little bit of a
question like what's ready for
real deployment and release
versus
hey let's use that to generate some
things that is then static that we're
giving to the players
um versus yeah it's generated on the fly
but it's definitely coming it's
definitely coming and I think you'll see
it in in the types of games that we do
it has great you know application I love
the idea that you'll be
using that to design different uh NPCs
and then testing if they're if they're
good enough if they're like um a little
too crazy you don't want like the the
super right but if we go back to it
being reactive some of that bot stuff
you know it's pretty it's incredible
it's then Translating that into voice
and then is that being done
by the client is it being done on a
server is it baked into the game there's
like different flavors of it
so there's still computational
challenges like how do you actually make
that happen right